[MUSIC PLAYING]
GUS CLASS: Hello, GDD Europe.
Thank you for coming out.
And thank you for
coming in for my talk.
I'm Gus Class.
And I'm a developer programs
engineer on the Google Cloud
IoT Core product.
And today, I'm going to be
talking about Google Cloud IoT
Core.
This talk is it
technical deep dive.
This means that I don't be
starting at the high level,
going over the architecture
of the products,
and then covering
the product features,
and then finishing low
level by just giving you
a quick demo with the product.
I want to warn you
before I get through this
is that I'm going to be
covering a whole lot of things.
And as an unfortunate
side effect,
the slides came out a little bit
denser than I would have liked.
So you may be tempted
to read all the material
on the slides and all
the text on the diagrams,
but please resist.
It's a trap.
So I'm going to do my best
to make the slides available
shortly after the talk.
So you can take it all in,
and you can take your time,
and enjoy the content of
the slides, and look at it
in more detail.
The whole thing is going
to be streamed as well.
And it's recorded.
So don't feel like you
need to take pictures.
If something really kind of
jumps out at you as important,
write that down and
use it as a takeaway.
But just kind of let
it go along as it goes.
And understand that we're
covering a lot of material
here.
So let's start with some
foundational concepts.
If you saw a talk before on
IoT, the speaker probably
start with something to
the effect of in X years,
you're going to have
more devices connected
to the internet than people.
The reality is that
this event horizon
has long since passed us.
And we're starting to
see, instead, like,
a trend where there
are going to be
more connected devices than
there are devices that are not
connected.
And so is does IoT really?
IoT is taking devices that were
not traditionally connected
to the internet and then adding
internet connectivity to them.
And when you talk about IoT,
you have to kind of scope it.
Because there's a lot of
different types of IoT.
And I like to think about it
in these three categories.
You've got homebrew
and enthusiast.
So you've got people that are
taking devices like Arduinos.
And then you're having
them internet connected.
And then these
internet connectivity
gives you capabilities that
you didn't have before.
So for example, I like
to think of it as like,
I had a smart flower
watering system.
And before I was
using data logging.
And now I have
internet connectivity
to do that data logging.
And Google provides
a lot of this stuff
to hobbyists in the AIY product.
And then the other area that
we have is consumer in devices.
And so this is
things like you've
got a fire alarm or
a smoke detector.
And then you
internet connect it.
So then it can talk
to other devices
and do intelligent things.
And so Google offers a lot
of these things with Nest.
And then the last thing
I want to talk about
is industrial and
commercial domain.
And so this is where you have
something like a factory where
you would have, traditionally,
just some mechanical assembly
line.
And then now we've
taken that factory
and added a lot
of sensors to it.
And we've added a
lot of capabilities
that we know what's
going on in that factory.
And now we're taking
that data and then
we're putting it into the
cloud, so that we can do
intelligent things with that.
And so that last domain
that I mentioned,
industrial and
commercial, is really
where Cloud IoT Core shines.
And for the consumer
device features,
you should really check
out Android Things.
So why should you care
about Cloud IoT Core?
I like to think
about it like this.
If you like me, then you
did some homebrew and
enthusiast-scale IoT.
You were building a
device for just yourself.
And so you weren't really
worried about things
like delegating your devices,
securing it against attackers.
Because you have sort of a
security through obscurity.
And you have an audience of one.
You know how to manage
that device and so forth.
But what if you were building,
say, 1,000 devices, or 10,000
devices, or you're moving
up to a million devices?
And all of these devices need
to be set up, configured,
provisioned, secured.
And then you need to scale out,
so that when those devices are
producing tons of data ingress
that you're able to handle it.
And so this is
where Cloud shines.
So we have these
systems where you
don't have to worry about the
capacity that you're creating.
The system will automatically
scale up and down to the needs
that you have.
And so this is why you should
care about Google Cloud IoT
Core.
So I'm going to give
you some background on,
what is Cloud IoT Core?
So just bear with
me as I tell you
about the products
that are important.
And then we'll be able to
get into the exciting usage
scenarios that we
expect developers to do.
So on the left I
have Cloud IoT Core.
And currently, it's a way
of creating a registry where
you can define where
devices are and then
connecting your
constrained devices
using MQTT to then
take your data
and then put it into Pub/Sub.
And once that data
is in Pub/Sub,
your data is in Google's Cloud.
And what that means is that
you can use Cloud Functions
to trigger API calls.
Or you can use Dataflow to
extract that data from Pub/Sub
and then put it into a data
warehouse, such as Bigtable
or BigQuery, and then
do data analytics on it.
So I'm going to tell
you a little bit more
about those products, so that
you can understand this better.
So what is MQTT?
If you've worked in
IoT before, you've
probably heard about MQTT.
It is a standard that was
designed by IBM in the '90s.
And it allows you to securely
connect devices, and transmit
data, and receive messages
from a published subscribe-like
solution.
It's a binary protocol, so it's
very efficient on the line.
And it won't use as much power
or require as much processing
power as a lot of
other protocols
that you may be familiar with.
And so it's sort of
the de facto standard,
which is why Google adopted it.
So what is Google Cloud Pub/Sub?
Google Cloud Pub/Sub
is a very efficient,
automatically managed scale to
solution for message publishing
and subscribing.
So you create these topics.
And then you can
subscribe to those topics.
And you can receive
payloads that
were pushed into those topics.
And it's globally distributed.
And it's reliable.
So when you send messages
through Google Cloud Pub/Sub,
you know that they will be
received by the subscribers
at least once.
And so when you have this large,
globally-distributed system,
you have to make
certain trade-offs.
And one of those trade-offs is
that you don't know the order
that the messages came in.
Another is that
the messages only
last inside of that store
for about seven days.
So what do you do about that?
And this is the
last product that I
want to talk about
before we start
talking about Architectures.
So this is DataFlow.
What DataFlow does
is it allows you
to take the stream of messages
that come in through Pub/Sub,
and then ensure they're
ordered it correctly,
or make sure that they are
only once existing inside
of your persistent data stores.
And then you can take them
and put them in other places.
So you can ETL from Pub/Sub
very easily using DataFlow.
So what services are
in Cloud IoT Core?
And this is what I
talked about very briefly
in that first diagram showing
high-level architecture
for Cloud IoT.
There is a Device
Manager, which I
like to think of as just
the identity solution.
This Device Manager
knows which devices
can connect to this bridge.
And then it also will keep
track of the last time--
all sorts of metadata
for those devices,
such as the last
time it connected
and the last time
that configuration
was sent to a device.
And the Device
Manager also allows
you to send specific
configurations down
to a device.
And I'll talk more
about this in a minute.
So the MQTT bridge
is something that
works hand-in-hand
with the Device Manager
to allow you to communicate
directly to a single Pub/Sub
queue.
And so given these
collections of services,
you can then start to
create IoT solutions that
are tailored to specific
domains or problems.
And again, this goes back
to the commercial industrial
applications first.
And other architectures
and other platforms
can use it as well.
But when you think about this
in the context of Android
Things and other
solutions, it's really
well-tailored to
industrial applications.
So the first thing
I want to talk about
is telemetry analytics.
And this is when
you have something
like large numbers of
weather stations distributed
around the world that are
each simultaneously recording
temperature data, barometric
pressure data, or position data
if they are moving around.
And in this scenario,
what you typically have
is all those devices
connecting with massive fan-in
to Cloud IoT Core.
And then Cloud IoT Core is going
to work one-to-one with Pub/Sub
to take that data and then
put it into Google's Cloud.
And then you would
typically use DataFlow
to take that data
and then put it
into a more persistent
place for analytics
in Bigtable or BigQuery.
And then once that's
there, you can
use Google's analytic products,
such as Datalab and Data
Studio to readily
analyze your data,
and then make
predictions, and so forth.
So the second scenario
I want to talk about
is device-to-device
communication.
And so this is when
you have one device.
And that device could be
an Android Things device.
Or it could be a
memory-constrained device
like an ESP8266.
And that device is
then going to try
to trigger another state on
another device to change.
So we built a demo
around this where
we had all of these
sensors inside of a room.
And the sensors were redundant,
so that the objective
was, when the room temperature
reached a certain temperature,
we would then have
another device that
would turn on a fan.
And so in this scenario,
you'd have all these devices.
And these devices could
be Android Things.
Or they could be
memory-constrained devices.
And then that
device would connect
to Cloud IoT Core,
which would then
pump the data into Pub/Sub,
which you can then aggregate
and extract using DataFlow.
And then you could
use a cloud function
to go back to the Device
Manager for Cloud IoT Core
to send a configuration
change to a second device.
And then that
second device could
have-- the configuration change
could say something like, turn
on your fan, start pumping water
out of the room, and so forth.
And so I'm going to show
you one more pattern.
Then we're going to start
talking about the platform
itself.
And this last pattern is the
same thing that we had before,
but I want to put in Android
Things device in there
explicitly.
Because we want
to have something
like state change
shared or shared
state between that
device and, say,
an Android companion
app or other web views.
So if you have some
sort of God view
for, say, a warehouse
that has all of these fans
and controls that get actuated,
you could share that state
and then see that state
from a Firebase database.
So in this scenario, I'll just
walk through it really quickly.
You have this device.
And then it connects
to Cloud IoT Core.
And then Cloud IoT Core
will take that data
and put it into Pub/Sub, which
then can go through DataFlow,
which then it can directly
trigger state changes inside
of that Firebase
real time database.
And then because
the state change
is consistent between that
database and Android Things,
then the state
could be triggered
to turn on a light bulb.
So in this specific
example, I was
thinking of the first device
or a collection of devices
has something like a
photovoltaic sensor,
so that when a room goes
dark, the lights turn on.
And so this is the
foundation for kind
of thinking about the ways
that you can use this platform
to do all sorts
of powerful things
that people want to do with IoT.
So now it's time to
talk a little bit
about the first service that
is enabled through Cloud IoT
Core, the Device Manager.
And so I like to think
about the Device Manager
as an identity provider.
And so what this
means is that it
knows the devices and
their credentials that
can connect to the service,
so that they can then
stream their data to us.
So the Device Manager
uses a resource model.
And devices are defined by
using-- so there's a hierarchy.
So you have each device
associated with configuration
at the bottom.
And that device
also will contain
individual configuration.
And then those devices are
placed into a registry, which
contains all those devices.
And then you can
programmatically
add, remove, list, and
so forth these devices.
So Registry is a way that
you can logically encapsulate
devices into a store.
And in doing so,
registries map devices
from the protocol bridge
in Cloud Pub/Sub topics
and subscriptions to Pub/Sub.
So typically, what
you're going to do
is you're going to have a
registry that map, then,
to a Pub/Sub topic.
And then you're going
to probably extract
that data from that Pub/Sub
topic using DataFlow.
And you're probably
going to want
to have a single place where
all that data is going.
And so we recommend that you
logically map everything just
to a single Pub/Sub
topic and just
have a single
registry per project.
So before you can add
devices to a registry,
you have to be able to
create that registry.
And so we have all
of these solutions
for creating registries,
listing registries,
deleting registries.
And you can do it
all programmatically,
because we envision that
there's a lot of different ways
that people will use this.
In certain scenarios, you would
have a device manufacturer
who is going to be
pre-provisioning
all of your devices for you.
And so you may want
to have them producing
the registries for you.
And so you can delegate
these permissions
to a device manufacturer,
so that they
can do that and manufacture.
And then in other
scenarios, you're
going to want to be able to do
the device provisioning later.
And so in this way, we
also support that scenario.
Before you can
connect a device, you
have to create that device
inside a device registry.
And so we have what
you would expect.
It's a basic CRUD API for
creating, deleting, reading,
and listing and so
forth your devices.
And each of the devices,
when you create them,
will have a unique
identifier that's
associated with the device
that is returned from the API
when you create that device.
You can also get the device
and then get this information.
But if you look in the
JSON representation,
which is probably really
hard to see on the screen--
but the JSON representation
has all of this meta data
associated with the device.
For example, you
know the last time
that a configuration
was set to the device.
And you know the last time the
device connected, and so forth.
And so this is sort
of the magic of where
the device or the Device
Manager comes in place.
Because your device
is connecting
and because we have
identity for that device,
we know the last time
configuration changes
came to that device and
information, such as the state
of the device.
So again, you can
delegate the permissions
for device creation,
deletion, and so forth
to your manufacturer
if you choose to.
Or you can do it yourself.
And so this is a good point
to talk about Identity.
So Identity is knowing
which device has connected.
And this is the magic
where all that metadata,
such as the last heartbeat
that came from a device,
is made available and things
like when configuration
changes came down to a device.
And so when you create
the identity for a device,
you're going to use asymmetric
encryption to give Google
your public key that is
associated with the device
credential.
And then your private key
will be on the device,
so that you can use
that private key
to create an encrypted
payload that you send
to Google when you connect.
And something that's kind
of special about our device
configuration is
that we allow you
to create multiple certificates
and then associate them
with the device, so that
you can rotate and expire
those certificates.
So you would do
something like, I
want to create a device today.
And then I'm going to
create three certificates.
The first certificate expires
in a year, the second, two,
and then the third in three.
And that way, you are
effectively rotating your keys
for your device credentials.
And I want to note, never
send anyone your private key.
It's like just writing
your password down.
OK.
So device configuration
is the next thing
I want to talk about.
Every device, individually,
has a configuration
associated with it that is
maintained by the Device
Manager.
And so what this means is
that you have something
like the state of the device.
Or if you wanted to
have the fan turned on,
you could represent
that in binary data
that's encoded as a JSON string.
And
But you could also
do something like use
a machine learning
model that you pass down
to a device that is stored
inside of binary data.
And then that machine
learning model
could be updated on the fly
with a configuration change.
And so again, so device
configuration is binary data
but you're welcome to encode
other data and send it as that.
And we did this
so that people can
have the flexibility for being
able to send all sorts of data
down to their devices.
And the Device Manager maintains
10 versions of configurations
that you can roll back
if something goes wrong
when you send out a
configuration change.
And another technical detail of
device configuration is that,
whenever your device
configuration is changed--
so you send a new version of the
configuration associated with
the device--
that device will
receive a notification
in its MQTT subscription that
contains the device change.
And you also get the
configuration every time
that you check.
And developers can also
patch an old version
and then do something
like rollback
to it if you want to
use the API in that way.
Anytime that a configuration
comes down to a device,
the device will notify Google
that it has acknowledged
that configuration change.
And this is done because we
have at least once delivery
of messages.
And the configuration could
come down to your device
more than once.
So a couple more
details about Identity,
when you connect to
our MQTT endpoint,
you need to use TLS 1.1 or 1.2.
And you need to use
MQTT version 3.1.1
I encountered some
issues in the past
with using the wrong version.
And going back to
Pub/Sub, so Pub/Sub
has at least once
delivery, but not
exactly once delivery
is the trade off.
So we don't support MQTT
QLS-2, instead, only QLS-1.
So typically, the
way that you use MQTT
is you specify the QLS when
you create a connection string.
And so just make sure
that you're using MQTT 1,
you're using QLS-1 and TLS 1.2.
And so we make our
connection endpoint globally
available at
mqqt.googleapis.com.
And we support two ports, the
8883, which is the standard TLS
port for MQTT, and
then port 443, which
is more firewall-friendly.
And so the last thing
I want to talk about
before doing a quick
demo is the MQTT bridge.
And this is the way that you
send the configuration change
down to a device using the
Device Manager and the way that
you can do something like send
telemetry data-- for example,
weather station data in one
of those examples earlier--
back to Google to store in
Cloud and then warehouse
for analytics for later.
So authentication, again, is
done using an MQTT client ID.
So the ID is something
like the connection string.
And that ID is going to
be unique per device.
And then the other thing is that
you need that username, which
Google ignores.
So you can put anything in
your username name field.
And then for the password,
you have to calculate a JWT.
And the JWT is a token that
has an expiration, so that,
this way, you can prevent
against certain types
of brute force attacks.
And because that
JWT expires, you
need to have an expiration
time and an issue at time that
is calculated consistently
with what Google expects.
And so you can use
Google's NTP server--
which is time.google.com--
in order to get for free
a issued at time and then
use that to calculate the
expiration for your JWT.
So when you publish data--
so the telemetry data
or a configuration change
trigger from a device,
you're going to use
the MQTT bridge.
And you must use this pattern
of devices/device-id/events.
And anything that
comes after events
is going to be created with
additional metadata, which
we refer to as a subtopic.
And so if you wanted to create
something like an alert,
you would put that in
devices/device-id/events/alerts.
And then when you would get
that data coming into Pub/Sub,
it would have that
information that is an alert.
And so when you want
to receive a device,
or when you want to receive
information on your devices,
you're going to need to
subscribe to a topic.
And the topic that you
subscribe to must be
devices/device-id/config.
Because right now,
the only data that
can come down from Google
Cloud IoT Core to your devices
is configuration changes.
And so, again, the
device configuration
is received on the
device when you connect
and any time that the
configuration changes.
And the final detail that
I haven't mentioned before
is that you do not get
the version number inside
of the device configuration.
You're welcome to
insert it yourself.
Or you can also request
specific versions.
So now that you've gotten a
high-level overview of what
the platform is, I'm
going to do a quick demo
of just kind of how the
Device Manager works
and then how you
connect using MQTT.
So I'm going to create a
device with the name Hello GDD.
And then it's got to be
created in a registry
that I have already created
called MQTT Test Reg.
And then I'm going to use
the device certificate
that I already calculated.
And so when the
device gets created,
you receive back the identifier
that Google calculates for it,
as well as an instantiated
configuration for that device.
And so now that I've
created the device,
I should be able to connect
to the MQTT endpoint using
a JWT for that device calculated
using its public certificate.
So I'm to copy this, because I
keep forgetting my device IDs.
So I at least need to
specify the private key file,
the product ID, the registry
ID, and the device ID.
There we go.
Yes, maybe, OK!
Yes, so now--
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, thank you.
OK.
OK, so now the data should
be coming into Pub/Sub.
And this looks
really small to me.
There we go.
Now if I keep pulling
this, eventually, we
should start seeing
messages coming in.
Maybe I jumped the gun there.
Sometimes it takes a
little bit for the messages
to come through on Pub/Sub.
And imagine, if
you will, telemetry
messages coming in and
being listable from Pub/Sub.
So sometimes it can take a
little while for the messages
to appear.
And it seems as though
that's what's happening now.
But that's pretty
much all I have.
So if we can return
to the slides,
I have just one
more slide to show.
AUDIENCE: The
registry [INAUDIBLE]..
GUS CLASS: Oh, did I?
Let's see.
You caught the bug.
AUDIENCE: It's test, correct?
But when you're
readin the queue--
GUS CLASS: Oh, when
I'm reading the queue.
Oh, the reason
these are different
is that this is a subscription.
And then the Registry is
entirely independent of that.
So there is G Cloud Pub/Sub.
There's a topic that
you publish too.
There's a registry
associated with that topic.
And then there's a subscription
that pulls from that topic.
Yeah, so the subscription
name is going to be different.
But sometimes it does take
a minute for the messages
to get kind of
triggered inside there.
But I think that I'm doing
something else wrong.
But yeah, that's it.
So we're currently
in a private beta.
And if we go back
to the slides, we'll
be able to see where you can
get more information about that.
So if you go to
cloud.google.com/iotcore,
you can sign up for the beta.
And you can learn more about
the product, such as details.
And yeah, so it's like the
cusp of the exciting time
for this product.
Sometimes some
things don't work.
But we're kind of
working through that.
And so thank you for
attending my talk.
I really appreciate your time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]